[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tom silverstein has been covering the
packers for the milwaukee journal
sentinel covering the packers for over
30 years now ever had a situation like
this tom
yes
just just
just go back to brett favre you know i
it's like i'm doomed to cover this at
the end of a hall of famers career every
time so if jordan love becomes a hall of
famer and i last that long i'll be
expecting the same thing uh how would
you uh recap yesterday
it was it was crazy i
you know i didn't expect
uh
i didn't expect that rogers would
test positive and then find out he was
unvaccinated you know when he gave his
press conference on the 26th of august
and talked about being immunized it
struck me funny it really did because i
try to listen to his where he is he is a
craftsman when it comes to wordplay
but he started talking and talking more
about vaccination and and i bought into
it and i'm kicking myself today that i
didn't doubt it more
but it was a surprise and
you know it's it's the
time of covet and these things are
happening all over how complicit are the
packers in this
that's a good question i
i'm we're going to find out a little bit
i've got to think that there was
some rules
bent but
you know the thing about it is
everything is is recorded
in their facility
so if there were violations where was
the nfl because the nfl goes through
these violations or through these tapes
and that's where they end up finding
teams and and they've done it you know
at the raiders i forgot what the other
teams were
so i think the nfl is probably complicit
if indeed there were violations
what was the local reaction to this
well you know it's hard it's sort of
like the politics in this state you're
either on one side or the other either
love rogers or you're mad about what
happened
in the offseason and so those who are
mad about what happened in the
off-season are really mad today i mean
they're just dug in and those who love
them
i i it kind of depends where you weigh
in on the vaccination thing too i i
think those who are really
pro-vaccination are kind of losing their
um
love for him
i brought this up at the start of the
show
i think in roger's head his mind that he
was protected
his way that hey i i did research i did
it the holistic way now he did apply for
this and was turned down by the nfl but
he might have in his head thought hey
i'm i raised my antibodies and i'm
immunized
and he said yeah are you vaccinated
whoever asked the question he said yeah
and then
he said i'm immunized and then he goes
on to say but yeah it's a personal
choice and uh you know i'm not here to
basically say who showed or shouldn't
get you know vaccinated or not so i
that's what i was wondering here that
rogers may have thought he was
he was protected doing the right thing
yeah
i don't want to say that's a naive
thought then i mean
because
here's how i looked at it was this is a
contractually you know the rules here
were collectively bargained between the
nfl and the players union and rogers has
been part he was part of that
negotiation when they came up with the
the contract the last contract so he's
not dumb enough to know
but not know that this was a this is a
contractual thing it's right there it
says you have to have the moderna the
pfizer
or the other one that johnson and
johnson no other vaccines count it says
it right in the contract so i i don't
believe that
he knew what he was doing he knew
exactly what he was doing he he doesn't
believe in the vaccination and i feel he
should have just been honest about it
do the packers respond today
uh in what way
do does somebody get in front of a
camera or the microphone and explain
what they knew when they knew it you
know management what what what went on
behind the scenes here because
i was told by a source this morning the
packers you know from this person's
standpoint are complicit in this that
you know
they they may have not wanted to upset
aaron rodgers they may have wanted to
you know hey we're in it together we'll
take the bullet for you
we'll turn our head
yeah i i think that's probably there's
some truth to that i think i think there
were some rules bent uh i don't know to
what extent you know i've been told he's
he wears a mask but
you know from from just our standpoint
the media you know he didn't wear him at
press conferences and i don't know if
that's a violation that's still up in
the air
uh we didn't see it like on the sideline
or after gains you know like he knew he
was not vaccinated and walking up to
other players and things like that he
doesn't have to
but
it's hard to know exactly what was going
on behind the scenes and no i don't
think they'll address it i don't think
they'll say another word about their
role in it matt lafleur was pretty clear
yesterday that he's not saying anything
so
it'll come out investigation and
honestly i don't think anything's going
to come out of that they're not going to
slap
someone really hard for aaron rodgers
especially when
they're probably the nfl's probably
complicit in it as well
yeah i know but then you had the saints
got dinged on this the titans got dinged
on this the raiders got dinged on this
so i i don't think the packers are out
of the woods here all right jordan loves
expectations
what what should the expectations be for
jordan loves sunday
i i think there should be some
expectation i mean it's a it's a year
and a half into his career he's a
first-round pick
it's time i mean he he had a little bit
of action in the new orleans game and
moved the ball had like a 58-yard drive
until he
got sacked and fumbled at the five-yard
line
i think there's expectation this is
this is exactly his moment i think and
he's got to step up and be be that guy
and at least i mean he doesn't have to
beat the chiefs but he's got to play
competitively
you got a story either way if if love
plays well okay maybe we do have our
future if he doesn't play well
then
what's the story what's the angle there
it's not the end of the world it's
you know he's gonna get another chance i
don't think uh rogers i was going to say
far from unbelievable
i don't think rogers is going to play
against seattle i mean he's not free
until
um
november 13th
and then that's assuming everything is
okay so i think love could end up
starting two games and
we'll know then i mean they they've got
to make a judgment too after the season
now if i weren't
[Laughter]
win the super bowl and rogers decides he
wants to stay they still have to make a
decision you know is is maybe jordan
love if he balls out these next two
games they just decide we're going with
them you got ptsd i think when it comes
to packer core quarterbacks there can
anything compare to the drama that
surrounded farf
but that one
that one is branded on me you know like
like a big welt it just
it'll never i'll never get over that
period and so no i don't think this is
quite reaches that
but um it is interesting this one's a
little more interesting the other one
was just tedious and
brutal
uh the cold weather
uh home field advantage for the packers
you know when we get to the playoffs and
nfc title game i mean is that still real
do you think
it is to some degree i mean it wasn't
for
tampa bay last year and the reason was
because they have tom brady and because
they have a defense
but you know for teams like tennessee
came in and just got
you know they just weren't ready for it
and and just fell apart
so it kind of depends who you bring in
and which team but
i i tend to think it's only a factor if
it's just brutally cold you know if it's
just like zero degrees and it it hasn't
been like that
in a while
and even even then if you remember um
jim harbaugh brought a team in in the
playoffs and it was just
ghastly cold and they beat the packers
so i don't think it's like a cure-all
it's that rogers because he's so skilled
and
able to play in the cold that that's why
they win it was the same with fire
great stuff tom i know you got a busy
day ahead of you we appreciate your time
as always
yeah it was great being with you take
care that's uh tom silverstein been
covering the packers for 30 years